ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
CUT BY ADAM [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO.
HUESO --
TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROB [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
INNER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS WOULD
ALL SENATORS AND OUR GAS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEADING
PRAYER THIS MORNING.
BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN DOCTOR
GEORGIA PRESCOTT SENIOR MINISTER
AT THE CENTER FOR SPIRITUAL
AWARENESS AFTER WHICH WE'RE
GONNA ASK ALL THE PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR STONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE BUT IT'S
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO ANCHOR
CELLS IN THE ONSCIOUSNESS OF
GREAT SPIRIT.
CALLED BY MANY NAMES GOD.
A LAW BELOW HIM THE SACRED
GRANDMOTHER TREE.
INFINITE INTELLIGENCE DIVINE
WISDOM.
WE GIVE THANKS FOR THIS PLACE
CALLED THE CELL CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE TODAY.
AND THANKS ALSO FOR THE SENATORS
AND STAFF WHO WORK SO HARD. FOR
A PROSPEROUS AND HARMONIOUS
CALIFORNIA.
MAY THERE BE WISDOM IN THIS
PLACE TODAY BUT ESPECIALLY MAY
BE A PLACE WHERE MEN.
AND WOMEN BECOME AWARE OF THE
DIVINE WISDOM WITHIN THEMSELVES.
MAY THERE BE CREATIVITY IN THIS
PLACE TODAY BUT ESPECIALLY MAY
IT BE A PLACE WHERE THE WOMEN
AND MEN ALLOW THE NATURAL
CREATIVITY THAT IS WITHIN THEM.
TO FLOW IN ANSWER TO THE STATE'S
CHALLENGES.
MAY THERE BE PATIENTS IN THIS
PLACE TODAY BUT ESPECIALLY MAY
BE A PLACE WHERE WOMEN AND MEN.
FIND THE PATIENTS WITHIN TO
LISTEN TO EACH OTHER WITH
RESPECT AND HONOR.
ESPECIALLY IN THIS WEEK OF
CELEBRATING THE COURAGE AND
WISDOM OF RIVER DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING.
MAY WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT RESPONSE TO EACH
OF OUR CITIZENS.
BASED ON THE CONTENT OF THEIR
CHARACTER NOT THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN WHO THEY LOVE.
HOW THEY PRAY OR WHAT GENDER
THEY EXPRESS?
THE EVERYONE COME INTO THE
SENATE WITH THE EXPECTATION OF
SUCCESS.
AND GO WITH THANKSGIVING
[inaudible]
HEY MATT.
PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE LACK
[inaudible]
SAY [inaudible]
AND YEAH [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ON THIS FRIDAY BEFORE MARTIN
LUTHER KING DAY WE WELCOME YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
AND WE LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
OUT WITH A SPECIAL RECOGNITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT ARE COLLEAGUES --
MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE AND
WELCOME --
BILL NAGEL TO THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE --
BILL IS THE PUBLISHER AND CEO OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE EYES
HAD DISTINGUISHED --
TWENTY NINE YEAR CAREER IN
PUBLISHING CON MOST RECENTLY
BEFORE HE JOINED THE CHRONICLE --
IT SERVED AS THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF SHARED AUDIENCE A* MEDIA
GROUP -- HE
WAS OUTSIDE --
TRIBUNE PUBLISHING --
AND WAS THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF TIMES FROM
200-092-2000 --
THIRTEEN HE'S BROUGHT TREMENDOUS
EXPERIENCE --
TO THIS GREAT INSTITUTION THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE --
AND PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MISTER NATAL TO THE FLOOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE WELCOME MISTER
NAGLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK SIR.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA BE A
ADVANCING.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. FOR NOW ADVANCING TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO WAY WILL BE WAY
FOR THE RULES COMMITTEE TO MEET
TODAY WITHOUT TWO DAYS NOTICE IN
THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR JANUARY
FOURTEENTH THROUGH THE
EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK.
WE'RE NOW MOVING FORWARD WITH
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS THAT ARE
READY FOR ACTION HERE TODAY.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO A DâN
ADVANCE TO FILE ITEM ONE SENATOR
BATES ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP.
SHE IS BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE BY SENATOR BATES RELATIVE
TO PRESIDENT GEORGE H. W. BUSH
DAY.
CENTER BATES GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS ARE I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THREE DECLARING JUNE TWELFTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS PRESIDENT
GEORGE H. W. BUSH DAY.
PRESIDENT BUSH SERVED AS THE
FORTY FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT HIS HOME IN HOUSTON
TEXAS.
HIS REMARKABLE ABILITY TO REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE IN ORDER TO GET
THINGS DONE WAS MENTIONED IN THE
NUMEROUS EULOGIES AT HIS
MEMORIAL SERVICE.
AND BY EDITORIAL WRITERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
BORN ON JUNE TWELFTH NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR FAMILY WITH THE
TRADITION OF PUBLIC SERVICE
GEORGE H. W. BUSH AND LISTED IN
THE UNITED STATES NAVY ON AS
EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY JUNE TWELFTH.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO AS THE
YOUNGEST PILOT IN THE NAVY BUSH
COURAGEOUSLY FLEW. FIFTY EIGHT
COMBAT MISSIONS DURING WORLD WAR
TWO SERVING AS A TORPEDO BOMBER
PILOT.
IN JANUARY NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
HE MARRIED BARBARA APPEARS THEY
HAD SIX CHILDREN GEORGE ROBIN
JOHN ON HIS JOB.
NEIL MARVIN AND DOROTHY.
AFTER HE WAS HONORABLY
DISCHARGED BUSH FOCUSED ON
COMPLETING HIS EDUCATION.
RAISING A FAMILY AND BEGINNING A
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE HE
SERVED TWO TERMS AS UNITED
STATES REPRESENTATIVE FROM TEXAS.
WAS APPOINTED TO A SERIES OF
HIGH LEVEL POSITIONS INCLUDING
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED NATIONS.
CHAIRMAN OF THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE CHIEF OF THE
UNITED STATES LIAISON OFFICE IN
THE PUBLIC'S REPUBLIC OF
PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF CHINA.
AND DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY HE SERVED AS
VICE PRESIDENT. TO PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN.
AND IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT HE
WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT IN THE
WORDS OF FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK
H. OBAMA.
AMERICA HAS LOST A PATRIOT IN
HUMBLE SERVANT IN GEORGE HERBERT
WALKER BUSH WELL OUR HEARTS ARE
HEAVY TODAY THEY'RE ALSO FIELD
WITH GRATITUDE.
NOT MERELY FOR THE YEARS HE
SPENT AS OUR FORTY FIRST
PRESIDENT BUT FOR THE MORE THAN
SEVENTY YEARS HE EXPANSION
DEVOTED SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY
HE LOVED.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES DO WE
HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR TO THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE CENTER NIELSEN.
THAT APPROACH --
BUSINESS PRESS LEADING GENERAL
THE SENATE THAT I TOO WOULD ASK
YOUR INDULGENCE.
TO ADJOURN IN HONOR OF GEORGE
HERBERT WALKER BUSH.
PROBABLY THE MOST PREPARED
PRESIDENT OR ONE OF THE MOST
PREPARED WE'VE EVER HAD.
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
PARTICULARLY FROM THE PUBLIC
SECTOR.
THE VARIOUS CAPACITIES IN WHICH
HE PERFORMED HIS DUTIES ALL WERE
DONE [inaudible]
SUCCESSFULLY.
IT WAS A GENTLEMAN.
A TRUE GENTLEMAN.
THE CAR LOT [inaudible]
ABOUT PEOPLE.
HE TOOK A STILL WORE.
BUT HE FASHION THE POWERFUL
COALITION OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
BEFORE HE DID THAT.
EXERTING THE KIND OF LEADERSHIP
THAT WAS REQUIRED [inaudible]
THE STOP [inaudible]
HUSSEIN.
BUT FURTHER HE HAD PROVIDED THE
LEADERSHIP. TO PREPARE OUR
MILITARY. TO TAKE ON SADDAM'S
VAUNTED FORCES.
THAT ALL THE PROGNOSTICATORS
SAID WE DARE NOT [inaudible]
CONFRONT.
IT IS A KIND MAN. ONE OF MY
DELIGHTFUL STORIES WITH HIM.
THE DAY HE WAS INAUGURATED WOULD
SATURDAY AND THEN THE NEXT DAY
SUNDAY WAS A NATIONAL DAY OF
PRAYER.
AT THE NATIONAL CATHEDRAL.
A MARYLAND I CAME IN AND WE
FIGURED WILL BE SOMEWHERE LOST
IN THE CROWD.
AND WE KEPT COMING TO THE
STATIONS OF SECURITY AND THEY
KEPT MOVING US FORWARD.
THE MOVING US FORWARD
[inaudible]
AND FOR AND WE END UP TWO ROWS
BEHIND THE BUSH FAMILY.
AND I SET DOWN.
AND THEN BOB ELIZABETH DOLE CAME
SITTING NEXT TO US.
WILL QUICKLY THEY MOVED TO
DOLE'S UP ANOTHER ROW BUT I TURN
TO MAIL IT SHOULD JUST LOOK LIKE
WE BELONG HERE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T.
SIMPLE.
AT BUT THE THE THE POINT WAS.
WHEN BUSH AUSSIE CAME OVER JUST
AS GRACIOUS AND FRIENDLY AS WE
WERE THE FAMILY?
AND AGAIN WE WORKED.
EN I HAVE A NUMBER OF HIS HAND
WRITTEN NOTES THAT HE WAS FAMOUS.
FOR THE PERSONAL TOUCH AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE EMPLOYED IN
MY CAREER TO AND WRITTEN
PERSONAL NOTE.
A POSITION THAT HE IS VERY
EASILY HELD BUT THAT HE TOOK
TIME. TO CARE ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
OTHER PEOPLE.
BRENT SIGNIFICANT THANKS.
BUT JUST BECAUSE HE WAS A
THOUGHTFUL AND GOOD MAN.
THAT HE HAD BARBARA WERE
MAGNIFICENT TEAM.
HE THE KIND OF STERN WIFE AND
GOD MOTHER THAT.
KEPT EVERYTHING ON TASK.
AND THEY HAD A LIFETIME.
ALONG LOVE.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL TO BEHOLD.
THE BEST WORD THAT I CAN SAY.
TO SOME UP GEORGE BUSH
[inaudible]
THIS DIGNITY.
THE WAS A MAN OF DIGNITY.
A MAN OF LEADERSHIP.
THAT A MAN WHO MADE A DIFFERENCE
FOR THE COUNTRY THAT HE LEFT.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR STONE GOOD MORNING SIR
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS PRESIDENT BUSH
WAS AN INSPIRATION.
TO MILLIONS OF WAS A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVANT.
HE WAS AN AMERICAN HERO AND
PATRIOT WHO IN ADDITION TO BEING
OUR FORTY FIRST PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ALSO.
SERVED AS A NAVAL AVIATOR AND
WILL WORK TO SERVE AS UNITED
STATES AMBASSADOR. TO THE UNITED
NATIONS.
SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTELLIGENT IN A CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY CIA.
AND SERVED AS A UNITED STATES
ENVOY TO CHINA.
WHAT PRESIDENT BUSH WAS A
PATRIOT WHO HELPED IN THE COLD
WAR WITH THE SOVIET UNION?
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AT HOME WERE
EQUALLY AS IMPRESSIVE.
HIS COMPASSION AND NAY FOR
NATURE HIS BELIEF IN HELPING
THOSE ARE NOT ABLE TO HELP
THEMSELVES.
DROVE HIM TO WORKING WITH
CONGRESS TO PASS THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
WE SHOULD LEARN FOR PRESIDENT
BUSH'S BELIEF THAT PEOPLE
DESERVE TO BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY.
IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR PHYSICAL
OR MENTAL DISABILITIES.
EVERY PERSON MATTER.
EVERY PERSON DESERVE TO BE CARED.
FOR THAT'S WHAT MAKES OUR NATION
GREAT AND THAT'S WHY AMERICA IS
A NATION.
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD THE
PEOPLE.
WISH TO EMULATE.
NAMING A DAY FOR PRESIDENT BUSH
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO BUT WE
CAN DO MORE TO HONOR HIM.
WE CAN TREAT ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED COMPASSIONATELY AND
PROVIDE MORE FOR THEM WE CAN
THANK OUR VETERANS OF PUT OUR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO DEFEND
AMERICA AT HOME.
AND ABROAD AND WE CAN WORK EVERY
DAY TO HELP THOSE IN NEED
PROVIDE A GOVERNMENT THE LESS
PEOPLE ACHIEVE THEIR HOPES AND
DREAMS WITHOUT GOVERNMENT
GETTING IN THE WAY.
PRESIDENT BUSH WAS MORE THAN OUR
FORTY FIRST PRESIDENT.
HE WAS A LEADER WHO LED WITH
COMPASSION HE WAS A SERVANT TO
BE.
SOUGHT TO HELP THOSE IN NEED AT
HOME HERE AND ABROAD.
HE WAS A NOR STAR OF THE
THOUSAND POINTS OF LIGHT THAT HE
CREATED.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AYE VOTE SCR
THREE RECOGNIZING JUNE TWELFTH.
AS GEORGE H. W. BUSH DAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
SENATORS ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
LEADER BATES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES I'D LIKE TO JUST FINISH FOR
THE FINAL QUOTE FROM OUR FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA BECAUSE I
THINK IT SAYS THAT ALL AND
CERTAINLY AT DOT.
IT SPEAKS TO ALL OF US HERE IN
WHAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO --
IN OUR LIVES IN IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO YOU --
THIS INSTITUTION.
OF PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID HE AND
AND COVERING THE SERVICE THAT
THE PRESIDENT TO H. W. BUSH HAD
PROVIDED.
WHAT A TESTAMENT TO THE
QUALITIES THAT MAKE THIS COUNTRY
GREAT?
SERVICE TO OTHERS COMMITMENT TO
LEAVING BEHIND SOMETHING BETTER.
SACRIFICE IN THE NAME OF LIFTING
THIS COUNTRY CLOSER TO ITS
FOUNDING IDEALS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM LEADER
BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
AYE ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
HI BELL [inaudible]
HI FORGES.
I BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS A HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROVE [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL [inaudible]
HI WISDOM.
HI -- DADA
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
OUR AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I AMBER.
I WAKE OWSKI [inaudible] FIVE
WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE ON TO ESSIE OUR NUMBER FIVE
SENATOR BRAD THIRTY PREPARE TO
TAKE UP.
HE IS BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIVE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
RELATIVE TO THE REVEREND DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
GOOD MORNING CENTER BRADFORD THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I STAND HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE CONCURRENT.
CURRENT RESOLUTION.
OF FIVE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS ARE
STANDARD TODAY IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING AND
I'M HONORED TO BE.
JOIN -- WITH
MY SENATE COLLEAGUE A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
SENATOR HOLLY MAY CHOOSE NOT
HERE TODAY.
AS THE CALL AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION IT AND NOT JUST
RECOGNIZING AND AND CELEBRATING
HIS BIRTHDAY BUT RECOGNIZING A
LIFE.
A LIFE THAT WAS WELL LET WAS
TAKEN FROM US WE WOULD ALL AGREE
FOR FAR TOO SOON BUT ALIVE THAT
WAS PURPOSEFUL IN ITS.
TIME DR KING ALSO OFTEN STATED
IT WASN'T.
THE QUANTITY OF A LIFE THAT
MATTERED BUT THE QUALITY I THINK
WE'D ALL AGREE THAT HE LIVED A
QUALITY A QUALITY LIFE.
A LIFE BILL WITH MANY OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS A LIFE OF EARLY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS SO MUCH SO THAT
WHEN HE ENTERED KINDERGARTEN AT
DATE FIVE YOU WOULD SO MARRED.
FAR VANCE OF HIS COLLEAGUES THAT
THE SCRIPT IN TO THE FIRST GRADE
A INDIVIDUAL WHO GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL AT FIFTEEN I INDIVIDUAL
WHO GRADUATED COLLEGE AT
NINETEEN I INDIVIDUAL WHO
ACQUIRED A PHD BY THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AND IT'S STILL THE
YOUNGEST MAN IN HISTORY.
AT THE AGE OF THIRTY FIVE TO
RECEIVE THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE A
LIFE THAT HAS BEEN WE WOULD ALL
AGREE.
DESPITE ALL OF OUR POLITICAL AND
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OUR
LIVES PALE IN COMPARISON TO
INDIVIDUAL WHO ONLY LIVE A SHORT.
THIRTY NINE YEARS.
BUT HE CHANGE THE COURSE OF THIS
NATION HE CHANGED THE COURSE OF
THIS WORLD AS IT RELATES.
TO RACIAL.
RELATIONSHIPS INTEGRATION OF
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
HE'S OFTEN REMEMBERED FOR HIS
MOST FAMOUS SPEECH I HAVE A
DREAM BUT WE KNOW THE TRUTH.
THAT WAS NEVER THE SPEECH THAT
DOCTOR KING INTENDED ON GIVING
THAT DAY IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
BEGINNING OF THAT SPEECH IT'S
ABOUT.
A PROMISSORY NOTE THAT THIS
NATION HAD MADE A HUNDRED YEARS
FROM THAT DAY AT THE SILENT
CITED OF THE EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY STOOD IN
FRONT OF EIGHTEEN SIXTY THREE
LINCOLN IT SIGNED EMANCIPATION
PROCLAMATION PROMISING FREEDOM
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND KING WAS STATING A
HUNDRED YEARS LATER WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR THOSE THAT JUSTICE.
A HUNDRED YEARS LATER THE NEGRO
STILL STILL LIVES IN SEGREGATED
HOUSING A HUNDRED YEARS LATER
THE NEGRO IS STILL NOT A CORE OF
ACQUIREMENT AFFORDED.
A QUALITY EDUCATION.
BUT IT'S DURING THAT SPEECH.
THAT THE FAMOUS.
GOSPEL SINGER MAHALIA JACKSON
YELLED TO HIM TELL ABOUT THE
DREAM MARTIN PELHAM ABOUT THE
DREAM.
AND THEN IT'S WHEN HE WENT INTO
I HAVE A DREAM BUT MANY TIMES WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND AND THE THE
REFERENCE IN THE BEGINNING OF
THAT SPEECH.
MANY TIMES PEOPLE GIVE DOCTOR
KING CREDIT FOR THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON HE WOULD TELL YOU HE
WAS ONE OF NINETEEN SPEAKERS AT
DAY.
AND HE WAS A SIXTEEN PERSON TO
SPEAK.
BUT HE WAS SO POWERFUL IN THE
MESSAGE THAT HE DELIVERED HIS
FOREVER MEMORIALIZED FOR THAT
BUT MANY FILLED REALIZE DOCTOR
KING ALSO AUTHORED.
OVER FIVE BOOKS.
AND THERE WERE SEVERAL ATTEMPTS
ON HIS LIFE AND YES WE LOST SOME
TRAGICALLY AND MEMPHIS TENNESSEE.
AND NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BUT MANY
FELT THAT RELY TO REALIZE THAT
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX THERE WAS
A BOMBING OF HIS HOME WHERE HIS
WIFE AND HIS YOUNG CHAO WAS
THERE.
AND LIKELY NO ONE WAS HURT.
AND NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHILE
ON A BOOK TOUR NEW YORK A SIGN A
BOOK A DERANGED WOMAN WALKED UP
TO HIM AND STABBED HIM WITH.
A LETTER OPENER ANYWAY THE
HOSPITAL WERE YOU RECEIVE THE
FINEST CARE.
AND IT WAS REPORTED THE NEXT DAY.
THAT HE WAS WITHIN INCHES OF
LOSING HIS LIFE THAT DAY.
AND HE SAID HIT HE SNEEZED THAT
DAY.
HE WOULD HAVE DIED.
AND WHILE HE WAS RECUPERATING IN
HOSPITAL HE WAS VISITED BY A
LITTLE GIRL.
AND HER ONLY WORSE TO HIM AS HE
RECUPERATED WAS THANK YOU DOCTOR
KING FOR NOT SNEEZING.
SO I SAY THANK DR KING FOR NOT
SNEEZING BUT I ALSO SAY THANK
HIM FOR HIS LIFE OF COURAGE OF
LOVE OF UNITY.
HE'S OFTEN STATED AND I WILL
QUOTE.
A GENUINE LEADER IS NOT IN A
SEARCHER OF CONSENSUS BUT A
MOTOR OF CONSENSUS WE AS
LEGISLATORS SHOULD TAKE HEED TO
THAT MESSAGE AND UNDERSTAND WE
SHOULD BE.
IN SEARCH OF CONSENSUS IN THE
THINGS THAT WE DO WHETHER WE'RE
DEMOCRAT A REPUBLIC BLACK OR
WHITE MALE OR FEMALE I. S. RIVAL
TODAY.
THERE BRADFORD THANK YOU FOR
THAT FITTING TRIBUTE TO DR KING.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE AN OPEN
IT UP FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WE'RE GONNA
GO CENTER DORADO SENATOR PAN
CENTER ALLEN CONSIDER WIENER.
BUT I'M SENATOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND A
MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS
MY PLEASURE TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF SCR FIVE WHICH COMMEMORATES
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF REVEREND
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
DR KING AS A SYMBOL OF JUSTICE.
HE WAS AN EDUCATOR OF CIVIL AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND A TEACHER OF NON BY.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE STRENGTH OF
HUMAN SOLIDARITY.
HE INSPIRED ARE LATINO CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS THAT'S OUR JOB IS
ON THE LINE AS WELL.
DURING THEIR STRUGGLES FOR
FARMWORKERS RIGHTS WHEN THEY
FACED ALL ODDS.
HE INSPIRED US TO STAND UP FOR
EQUAL ACCESS TO PUBLIC EDUCATION.
WHEN HE'S THE LA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WALKED OUT IN PROTEST?
ALL AMERICANS ALL AMERICANS
BENEFITTED FROM HIS COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP.
ESPECIALLY THE DISABLED AND
SENIOR COMMUNITIES LGBT Q.
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND WOMEN.
TODAY WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION AND SOME
OF THE SAME INJUSTICES THE
DOCTOR KING FOUGHT.
AND FOR WHICH SHE PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE.
HE WAS KILLED FIFTY ONE YEARS
AGO WHILE MARCHING.
WITH MEMPHIS SANITATION WORKERS
ON STRIKE. FOR SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS ARKAN COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO BE DEMONIZED AND
JUDGED.
ON THE COLOR OF OUR SKIN AND NOT
ON THE CONTENT OF OUR CHARACTER.
LIKE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN DYING
WHILE INCARCERATED.
TODAY LITTLE SIGNAL THE
COMMUNITY LEADERS TEACHERS YOU
ACTIVISTS WHO ARE UTILIZING DR
KING'S SPIRIT OF NON VIOLENCE TO
WIN SOCIAL EQUALITY AND JUSTICE.
I AM VERY PROUD TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION AND
WILL DO MY PART TO HONOR DOCTOR
KING.
BY ADVOCATING FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND ENSURING ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY FOR ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MADAM SENATOR
WE'D LIKE TO NOW GO TO SENATOR
PAN MORNING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LET'S THEY'VE CAUCUS
WHICH IF WHICH I'M PLEASED TO BE
A VICE CHAIR.
ARISING STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
YOU ARE FIVE AND ONE THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM GUARDINO FOR
BRINGING THIS SUPPORT RESOLUTION
FORD.
IT'S CERTAINLY AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE TO JOIN ALL OF YOU
TODAY AND RECOGNIZING DARDEN DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
AND IF IT'S AN INFLUENTIAL IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT LEADER WHO HAS
MADE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT AND
CHANGE OUR COUNTRY OUR HISTORY
AND TODAY --
THIS RESOLUTION REFLECT IN HONOR
OF DR KING'S WORK.
I CAN'T INSPIRED GENERATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS ORGANIZED.
AND MOVE TOWARD A BETTER WORLD
INCLUDING OUR ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE LEADERS LIKE DR KING THE
THANK AS HE WAS AMONG THOSE WHO
IGNITED THE FIRED INSPIRED CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS SUCH AS YURI
BUT JANA IN HER FIGHT FOR TRUTH
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AS WELL AS
GRACE LEE BOGGS WHO FAMOUSLY
HELP ORGANIZE DR KING'S WALK TO
FREEDOM IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
IN.
DETROIT SP A SPEECH THAT SPOKE
TO UNITY RESPECT AND HOPE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE MEMBERS AND FORMER
ATTORNEY TODD ENDO JOIN DR KING%
IN HIS MARCH TO SELMA FROM
ECONOMY.
AND SUPPORT OF VOTING RIGHTS AND
FIFTY YEARS LATER IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THIS IS IN THE MEMBERS
ARE INSPIRED TO VISIT SELMA ONCE
AGAIN.
IN COMMEMORATION OF DR KING'S
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
IN THESE TIMES WERE HOPE IS SO
ESSENTIAL TO PROGRESS WE THINK
DOCTOR KING FOR HIS LIFETIME
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION TO
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY AND HIS
SACRIFICE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN VOTING AYE ON
THE SUPPORT RESOLUTION IN HONOR
OF DR KING AND AGAIN I THINK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM GUARDINO FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
WITH A TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER
NOW TO SENATOR ALLEN.
THANK YOU SEE PRESENT MEMBERS IS
CHAIR OF OUR LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I WANT TO RISE AS WELL
AND RECOGNIZE.
THE LEGACY OF DR KING I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN SO INSPIRED BY HIS
STORY.
AND HAVE MADE PERSONAL
PILGRIMAGES --
IN ATLANTA AND ALSO THE NATIONAL
CIVIL RIGHTS MUSEUM IN MEMPHIS
WHICH IS AN EXTRAORDINARY PLACE
HAVE YOU EVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO --
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TO SEE --
THAT THAT THAT THAT.
TRAGIC IN SACRED SITE.
HI YOU THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY OF OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH DR KING IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY.
I THINK HE SAW AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PROTRACTED STRUGGLE
TO OVERCOME SLAVERY OPPRESSION
AND A BIRD A WHOLE ACOSTA.
I HISTORY THAT ECHOED HIS OWN IN
FACT IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE
WENT AND SPOKE TO THE NATIONAL
CONVENTION OF THE AMERICAN
JEWISH.
CONGRESS AND SAID THAT OUR UNITY
IS BORN OF OUR COMMON STRUGGLE
FOR CENTURIES NOT ONLY TO RID
OURSELVES OF BONDAGE BUT TO MAKE
OPPRESSION.
OF ANY PEOPLE BY OTHERS AN
IMPOSSIBILITY.
AND THROUGH HIS PROPHETIC
VISIONS IS PROFOUND SERMONS THAT
DREW VERY DEEPLY --
FROM THE OLD TESTAMENT.
DR KING CONVINCED GENERATIONS OF
JEWISH AMERICANS TO JOIN HIS
MARCHES FOR A QUALITY TO RAISE
THEIR VOICES IN THE CALL FOR
JUSTICE AND DEMAND.
THAT OUR COUNTRY RECOGNIZING
GUARANTEE THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
EVERYONE.
HIS LONG AND FINISH WORK OF TO
BREAK FREE FROM THE IN CITIES
SHADOWS OF BIGOTRY CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY HIS LEGACY ALREADY
MOMENTOUS CONTINUES. TO BE
WRITTEN.
AND WE ASK THAT.
ME DOCTOR KING REST EMPOWER
KNOWING THAT HIS DREAM.
WILL NEVER NEVER DIE.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN WE LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR WIENER IN
IN CENTER MORE LOCK THEIR WIENER
THE FLOORS OR SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT ARE COLLEAGUES AS
CHAIR OF THE LGBT CAUCUS I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT --
ZERO FIVE DR KING'S LEGACY FOR
MANY REASONS HOLD SIGNIFICANT
POWER FOR THE LGBT COMMUNITY --
HE IMPLORED PEOPLE TO BE JUDGED
BY THE CONTENT OF OUR CHARACTER
AND NOT ON IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS --
THAT ARE SIMPLY PART OF WHO WE
ARE --
HOWEVER I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY --
TO RAISE THE PROFILE --
WHO REALLY EXEMPLIFIED --
HIS --
INCLUSIVE APPROACH TO ACTIVISM --
BAIRD RUSS STERN WAS A BLACK GAY
MAN WHO --
WAS CREDITED WITH HELPING DR
KING LEARN GANDHI'S WAY OF
NONVIOLENCE.
A DESPITE THE CULTURE OF THE
TIME DR KING GAVE RUSTIN SEAT AT
THE TABLE --
RUSTIN WAS --
INTEGRAL TO THE ORGANIZATION OF
DR KING'S FAMOUS MARCH ON
WASHINGTON HE GATHERED
MARSHALL'S TRAFFIC DIRECTORS AND
SPEAKERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ABOUT.
DESPITE HIS SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION --
SOME WHO WERE CLOSE TO DOCTOR
KING I DID NOT WANT HIM TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS DUE TO
HIS SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
A DOCTOR CAME DID NOT GIVE IN TO
THAT PRESSURE --
DID NOT GIVE IN TO THE PRESSURE
TO FIRE --
RUSTIN --
WHICH REALLY SHOWCASES HOW FAR
AHEAD OF HIS TIME OUR DOCTOR
KING WAS.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT --
CORRETA SCOTT KING --
DOCTOR KING SEE IF AN ALLY TO
THE LGBT COMMUNITY CAN STILL BE
FELT TODAY AND EXTENDED WELL
BEYOND DOCTOR KING STUFF.
ON MRS KANE FREQUENTLY OF
KNOWLEDGE THE LGBT PEOPLE WHO
STOOD UP AND FOUGHT FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
PEOPLE --
SHE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE LINKS
BETWEEN RACISM HOMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI SEMITISM --
AS SIMPLY DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
HE DE HUMANIZING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY --
I WANT TO CLOSE WITH A QUOTE
FROM CHRIS* NâNG --
ISSUE REST IN PEACE --
QUOTE I STILL HEAR PEOPLE SAY
THAT I SHOULD NOT BE TALKING
ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF LESBIANS AND
GAY PEOPLE.
AREN'T THAT I SHOULD STICK TO
THE ISSUE OF ACIAL JUSTICE.
BUT I HASTEN TO REMIND THEM THAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING SAID QUOTE
INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A THREAT
TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
AND QUOTE A COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL
MAKE YOU CENTER WINNER.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER SENATOR MORE LIFE
GOOD MORNING SIR.
MORNING MISTER PRESIDENT YOU'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB MORNING SIR.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S A LITTLE OLDER
NOW -- THE
ASSASSINATIONS OF JOHN F.
KENNEDY IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
AND ROBERT KENNEDY IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT MARTIN LUTHER KING
ALSO.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT MADE A A
PRETTY BIG IMPRESSION ON THIS
YOUNG [inaudible]
PERSON.
AND I WANT TO CONCUR WITH THE
SENATOR FROM REDONDO BEACH.
IF YOU EVER HAVE THE CHANCE TO
VISIT.
THE STATE OF TENNESSEE.
AND IF YOU EVER FIND YOURSELF IN
THE CITY OF MEMPHIS.
PLEASE PLEASE VISIT THE NATIONAL
CIVIL RIGHTS MUSEUM.
LOCATED AT THE LORRAINE MOTEL
WHERE MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS
ASSASSINATED.
IT IS MOVING.
IT IS POWERFUL.
AND IT IS.
A FINE TRIBUTE TO THE MEMORY OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
AND I VOTE ON SCR FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THINKING THIS
IS SENATOR.
EDITORS.
WE'D LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R..
FIVE I PERSONALLY FIND DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING TO BE ONE OF
THE MOST INSPIRING PEOPLE WHO'VE
EVER WALKED THIS WORK BIRTH HE
SAID SO MANY THINGS THAT I THINK
WE CAN ALL TAKE SOLACE IN I
THINK WE CAN ALL BE INSPIRED BY.
BUT TODAY THE QUOTE I THINK THAT
REALLY FITS DURING THESE TIMES
IS THE FOLLOWING.
DARKNESS CANNOT DRIVE OUT
DARKNESS ONLY LIGHT CAN DO THAT
HATE CANNOT DRIVE OUT HATE.
ONLY LOVE CAN DO THAT AND I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT THE BEST WAY
TO HONOR DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING IS TO SHINE MORE LIGHT AND
TO LOVE MORE.
AYE VOTE --
I SORRY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SCR.
FIVE THE COMMISSION SENATOR
MEMBERS ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
LENDING THEIR VOICE TO THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION --
RECOGNIZING THIS IMPORTANT LIFE
AND ADDS WE OUR WAY FROM HERE ON
MONDAY I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
DON'T LOOK AT IT AS A DAY OFF.
BUT A DAY ON A DAY ON FOR
SERVICE OF GIVING BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AS DOCTOR KING WOULD
WANT US TO DO NOT A DATA.
YOU KNOW HAVE A GOOD TIME AND
AMPLE RATES BUT THE THINK ABOUT
WHAT THIS MAN STOOD.
FOR AND IT JUST DAWNED ON ME THE
OTHER DAY.
DR KING OUTSIDE OF GEORGE
WASHINGTON WHICH IS NOW
PRESIDENT'S DAY IS THE ONLY
AMERICAN WHO HAS A NATIONAL
HOLIDAY IN HIS HONOR.
THERE'S ONLY TWO PEOPLE GEORGE
WASHINGTON AND MARTIN LUTHER
KING SO WE SHOULD.
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THAT THIS
MAN HIS HEAD NOT ONLY ON THIS
NATION BUT ON THE WORLD AS A
WHOLE.
AND THERE ARE MANY QUOTES AS AS
WE'VE HEARD --
WE WE REFERENCE OFTEN BY OUR BY
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE TO
MORE AS WELL.
WE ARE NOT MAKERS OF HISTORY
WERE MADE BY HISTORY AND FAR TOO
OFTEN WE FIND OURSELVES TRYING
TO SHAPE WHAT WE WANT HISTORY TO
BE BUT WE'RE MADE BY HISTORY AND
DOCTOR KING.
CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD THAT.
AND THE ULTIMATE MEASURE OF A
MAN IS NOT WHERE THEY STAND IN
COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE BUT
WHERE THEY'RE STANDING CONFLICT
AND CHALLENGE.
MEMBERS WERE IN CONFLICT IN
CHALLENGE IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW. ONE COMPLICATING CHALLENGES
WITHIN THE STATE AS WE DEAL WITH
IMMIGRATION AS WE DEAL WITH
EDUCATION AS WE DEAL WITH.
JUST POLICE LAWS AND A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT DOCTOR
KING FOUGHT FOR FIFTY ONE YEARS
AGO STILL EXIST IN AMERICA TODAY.
AND WE SHOULD BE [inaudible]
AWAKE OR THE YOUNG FOLKS SAY
WOKE. TO THOSE ISSUES IN MAKING
SURE WE'RE MAKING OUR TIME HERE
NOT ONLY IN THIS LEGISLATOR BUT
ON THIS PLANET COUNT.
AGAIN HE LIVED ONLY THIRTY NINE
YEARS BUT HE MADE EVERY SECOND
COUNTS.
AND I'M GOING TO CLOSE WITH A
POEM BY DR BENJAMIN MAYS.
WHO IS A MENTOR TO DOCTOR KING
WHO WAS THE PRESIDENT OF
MOREHOUSE COLLEGE AND A GREAT
FAMILY FROM FRAN?
AND IT'S CALLED GOD'S MINUTE.
I'VE ONLY JUST A MINUTE.
ONLY SIXTY SECONDS SENATE.
FORCED UPON ME CAN'T REFUSE IT.
BEEN SEEK IT.
BEEN CHOOSE IT.
BUT IT'S UP TO ME TO USE IT.
I MUST SUFFER IF I LOSE IT.
GIVE AN ACCOUNT.
BY ABUSE IT.
JUST A TINY LITTLE MINUTE.
BUT ETERNITY IS SENATE WHAT WE
DON'T WANT OUR MINUTE MEMBERS I
ASK FOR A VOTE.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL VOTE.
SCENE IN HARRY NINE EYES THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE NOW TO ADVANCE OUR
LAST FILE ITEM THE DAY THAT
SENATOR HERTZBERG HE'S PREPARED
TO PRESENT MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE TWENTY FIFTH
RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE OF NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR MR MAJORITY LEADER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
SAW THIS IS INDEED A RESOLUTION
CELEBRATING THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
NORTHRIDGE.
BUT I DON'T USE THAT TERM IN THE
CONTEXT OF CELEBRATION.
BUT IN THE TERM THAT WAS JUST
REFERENCED ABOUT BEING MADE BY
HISTORY TO RESPECT HISTORY TO
REMEMBER HISTORY TO LEARN BY
HISTORY AND TO ACT FROM HISTORY.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
WE WOKE UP IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY TO A SIGNIFICANT
EARTHQUAKE.
THIS EXTRAORDINARY SIXTY
THOUSAND HOUSES.
ALMOST AS MANY LIVES WE'VE LOST
IN THE PARADISE FIRE TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF DAMAGE IN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
HOMELESS.
AND IS LUCY JONES SAID YESTERDAY
THAT EVENT TO CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE IT STILL WAS A VERY
SMALL EARTHQUAKE COMPARED TO
WHAT WE CAN OTHERWISE FACE.
AND SO THE THE ANY OTHER THING
THAT YOU SAID THAT I FOUND QUITE
ASTOUNDING.
IS THAT THE CHANCE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL EXPERIENCE A SIX
POINT SEVEN OR LARGER EARTHQUAKE
IN THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS.
IS 99%.
SO THE ONLY QUESTION IS WHEN
WHERE AND HOW BIG NOT THAT IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO WE NEED TO BE PREPARED OUR
JOB IN GOVERNMENT IN SO MANY
RESPECTS IN TERMS OF REPAIRING
THE LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN
DEALING WITH ALL THE OTHER
CHALLENGES TO BE THERE BE
AVAILABLE TO FIGURE IT OUT WE
KNOW.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN LET'S
GET AFTER IT AS SOME FAMOUS SON
OF THE GOVERNOR SAID FROM NEW
YORK.
WE HAVE A CENTER ON THIS FLOOR
THAT THE LAST FOUR YEARS FROM
SAN MATTEO WHO'S BEEN DILIGENTLY
GETTING THE FUNDING FOR EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM ELEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE NOTES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT GIVE YOU TEN
SECONDS. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
EARLY WARNING WHAT'S AT TEN
SECONDS FOR STOPPING ELEVATORS
OPENING DOORS FOR FIRES A
STATIONS THAT OTHERWISE COULD BE
CLOSE TO FIRST RESPONDERS CAN
GET OUT.
BEING ABLE TO GET OUT OF YOUR
HOME AND ALL SORTS SMALL STEP
AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE I THINK
IN THE COMING YEAR A NUMBER OF
OTHER.
MEASURES IN THIS LUCY JONES SAID
YESTERDAY.
THE EARTHQUAKE IS INEVITABLE.
BUT THE DISASTER IS NOT.
AND THAT IS UP TO US THAT IS UP
TO US IN TERMS OF OUR ROLE IN
GOVERNMENT SO I STAND HERE TODAY.
REALLY NOT SO MUCH IN
CELEBRATION OF THE ANNIVERSARY
BUT A REMEMBRANCE CALL THE
ACTION. FOR ALL OF US TO GET
AFTER IT.
I ASKED RIVAL [inaudible]
MAJORITY LEADER.
CENTER STERN AND THEN SENATOR
ALLEN SENATOR STERN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT JUST
BRIEFLY RISE JOIN MY COLLEAGUES --
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WE
SHARE NORTHRIDGE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE STANDING HERE
A YEAR FROM NOW MORNING.
OR TWO YEARS FROM NOW SAYING
WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE I WANT
TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE CAN DO NOW.
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS --
THE MAGNITUDE IS ALMOST TOO
LARGE. TO TO TO IMAGINE AND IT'S
A DIFFERENT ANIMAL THAN A FIRE
OR FLOOD --
THESE REALLY TO BLINDSIDE YOU
BUT THOSE SECONDS COUNT.
WE HAVE NEW TECHNOLOGY COMING
ONLINE BUT IT'S ABOUT THE
HOUSING STOCK IN LOOKING IT SOFT
STORY HOUSING AND ALL THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE VULNERABLE ALL
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES IN.
THE BAY AREA AND THROUGHOUT THIS
STATE WHO --
WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD THE DOLLARS
WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD THE
PREPARATION OR EVEN INSURANCE
FOR THE WHERE WITH ALL TO GET
AHEAD IT IS THE MOST VULNERABLE
OF US WILL BE EXPOSED BY THIS?
AND SO I WOULD JUST URGE TODAY
NOT JUST TO NOT JUST TO REMEMBER
BUT TO PREPARE.
THANK YOU THINK IT'S AN STERN.
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE CENTER ALLEN
FLOORS OR SECOND THE THE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE IN --
YOU KNOW I'VE I REMEMBER THAT
QUAKE VERY --
VERY INTENTLY IT WAS THE WEEKEND
OF THE MARLINS A KING DAY
WEEKEND AND AND MEMBER ALL OF
OUR ALL OF OUR DISHES AND
CONDIMENTS THAT WERE WERE ALL
OVER HER KITCHEN FLOOR --
AFTER THAT AFTER THE SEEKING.
AND WHEN IT SPENDING DAYS AND
DAYS CLEANING UP AND I'VE
ASSISTED WITH OUR LOCAL SCOUT
TROOP TO HELPING FOLKS WHOSE TO
ME TO COME DOWN IT WAS A REALLY
PROFOUND.
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY --
IN ON THE WEST SIDE BUT I WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE A PARTICULAR PERSON
WHO I THINK EXEMPLIFIES.
THE SERVICE OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOLKS AND I MEET
PEOPLE MAY REMEMBER OFFICER
CLEARANCE DEAN.
WHO WAS A MOTORCYCLE COP?
AFTER THE SHAKING.
FINISHED HE KNEW THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE NEEDED.
HE WAS GONNA BE NEEDED BECAUSE
HE KNEW WHAT A WHAT A WHAT A
POWERFUL EARTHQUAKE THAT HAD
EEN HE KNEW THERE WAS GOING TO
BE A LOT OF DAMAGE ALL THE POWER
WAS OUT I REMEMBER I CAN
ACTUALLY SEE THE THE STARS FOR
THE FIRST TIME NOT SOMETHING
THAT.
I WAS USED TO GROWING UP IN LOS
ANGELES.
AND HE LACED UP HIS HIS BOOTS
PUT ON HIS UNIFORM GOT NEWS
MOTORCYCLE AND STARTED TO REFER
TO DRIVE. TO GO TO HIS POLICE
STATION.
AND OF COURSE UNBEKNOWNST TO HIM
HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE FREEWAY
COLLAPSED.
AND HE SAILED RIGHT OFF.
THE EDGE OF THE FREEWAY IN THE
DARK.
AND IT WAS JUST A HE OBVIOUSLY
PASSED AWAY HE WAS ONE OF ABOUT
FIFTY PEOPLE WHO DIED DURING NOT
EARTHQUAKE.
BUT FOR ME AND ALWAYS WAS SUCH
AN IN DURING.
SYMBOL OF THE SACRIFICE OF AND
THE SENSE OF DUTY OF OUR FOLKS.
WHO ARE FIRST RESPONDERS AND I I
JUST WANT?
TO REMEMBER HIM AS PART OF THIS
COMMEMORATION.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
CENTER BELL GOOD MORNING SIR.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS THE
MEASURE I WANT A JOB REFLECT ON
IMPACT IT HAD ON ENGINEERING.
AND TRANSPORTATION --
SECTOR THAT WE WORK ON THE
RESULT OF THE EARTHQUAKES --
BOTH THE LOWER FOR THE
NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE'S WAS THAT
THERE WAS A COMPLETE OVERHAUL.
OF THE ENGINEERING STRUCTURAL
STANDARDS OF OUR OUR OUR STATE
HIGHWAY BRIDGES.
AS A RESULT --
A A LIST OF BRIDGES WAS CREATED.
TO STRUCTURALLY RECTOR.
OR REPLACE.
THE BRIDGES.
SO THE LEGACY OF THE DAMAGE
BRIDGES IN THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE.
WAS THAT --
WE ARE NOW CONDUCTING.
A REPLACEMENT SO WE'LL HAVE A
100% SEISMICALLY SAFE --
STRUCTURAL BRIDGES IN CALIFORNIA --
SP ONE WHICH RECENTLY PASSED
WILL COMPLETE THE FUNDING.
OF ALL THE STRUCTURAL --
SEISMIC --
STRUCTURAL REPLACEMENT OR REPAIR.
OF ALL THE BRIDGES IN CALIFORNIA
ON OUR HIGHWAYS SO.
WE ARE WE ARE REACHING THE GOAL.
THAT WAS CREATED AFTER.
THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE.
AND NOW I HOPE TO SEE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS.
A 100% SEISMICALLY SAFE --
STATE HIGHWAY BRIDGES.
THANK YOU CENTER BALLOTS MEMBERS.
LAST CALL.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE MAJORITY
LEADER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO STRESS THE POINT THAT WAS
JUST MADE WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE SEEN
GREAT PROGRESS IN CALIFORNIA IN
MANY AREAS.
DEALING WITH THE EARTHQUAKE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WERE A
FIFTEEN HUNDRED BUILDINGS AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RETROFITTED THEIR
STRONG NEW LAWS IN THAT REGARD
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE THE
SAME THING.
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM THAT I
EARLY WE WERE FREE FOR TWO AND
THE SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION BONDS
THAT WERE BUILT IN 982-000-22000
FOUR AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I
THINK ALL HAVE.
A STRICT STANDARDS FOR
EARTHQUAKES THAT FURTHER ENHANCE
AT A LEVEL OF THINKING IS THAT
WE AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF REGAUGED
RESPONSIBLY.
I'M JUST INFORMED BY THE NOTION
OF 99% CHANCES IN THE NEXT
THIRTY YEARS THE OBLIGATIONS
THAT WE ALL HAVE AND I JUST ON A
PERSONAL NOTE.
YOU KNOW IN THE EARTHQUAKE WHEN
WHEN I WAS THERE <c.green> SAW WAS A</c>
HUMAN STORY TO IT AND I REMEMBER
MY SON WHO WAS IN THE CRIB.
WHO WHO'S BOOKCASE FELL ON TOP
OF THE CRIB AND WE WOULDN'T
PANIC BUT HE WAS BURIED IN BOOKS
AND WE ROOM SIR WHAT IT WAS OKAY?
THERE'S ALWAYS IN ADDITION TO
THE ALL THE THE LOSSES AND
FINANCIAL LOSSES BUSINESSES THE
LIKE JUST AN EXTRAORDINARY
EMOTIONAL IN HUMAN TOLL TO THESE
THINGS I ASK YOUR AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU SIR.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
HEARING SEEN NO OBJECTION SIZE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
ADVANCE TEAM --
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS BY
THIS IS A TIME TO ADDRESS A
JOURNAL MEMORIES WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO HAVE A
RANGE -- I
JOURNAL MEMORIES TODAY IF YOU
HAVE NOT PRE ARRANGE YOUR
JOURNEY IN MEMORY IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SEE THE MAJORITY LEADER
AT THIS TIME.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FOR NOW WITH OUR FIRST SENATOR
WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES --
IT'S OF GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RIGHTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF LONG
TIME SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENTS
EDWARD AMEN MURPHY --
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY THIRD
AT THE AGE OF --
SIXTY THREE AMEN EMIGRATED FROM
IRELAND TO SAN FRANCISCO IN --
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THROUGH
HARD WORK AND PERSISTENCE HE
BECAME A SUCCESSFUL --
OUR CITY --
ANY SPARE TIME HE ENJOYED
READING GOING TO THE THEATER.
WATCHING HISTORY DOCUMENTARIES
AND SELLING SERVICES GO BACK --
IMMENSE SUCCESS STORY REALLY
EMBODIES --
THE AMERICAN DREAM OF AN
IMMIGRANT COMING TO THIS COUNTRY --
AND BUILDING SOMETHING HEARING
CREATING A LIFE --
HE WAS A LOVING FATHER OF TO THE
TRUSTED FRIENDS --
AND HE WAS ALWAYS THERE TO HELP --
GOES IN HIS COMMUNITY --
HE WAS A VERY WARM HEARTED
PERSON AND HAD A TERRIFIC SENSE
OF HUMOR --
HE SURVIVED BY HIS SONS JONATHAN
AND ADMIN MURPHY.
HIS LONGTIME COMPANION DENISE LE
POINTS --
AND HIS BROTHER --
SHAUN MURPHY OF COACH A MESS AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
CENTER WIENER PLEASE ACCEPT OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THIS PAST TUESDAY I RECEIVE SOME
VERY SAD NEWS THAT THE MAYOR OF
CATHEDRAL CITY AND MY VERY GOOD
FRIEND.
GREG PETTUS PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS FROM SURGERY.
THE PROBABLY SURPRISES MANY OF
YOU THE GREG AND I WERE GOOD
FRIENDS HE WAS A STAUNCH
DEMOCRAT.
HE WAS A PROUD PROGRESSIVE
LIBERAL.
I AM A STAUNCH REPUBLICAN AND A
PROUD CONSERVATIVE.
YOU MAY ASK WHAT BROUGHT US
TOGETHER.
AND THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE.
WE BOTH STROVE TO DO OUR BEST
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
GRAY GOT INVOLVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY AND I GOT
INVOLVED TWO YEARS EARLIER IN
THE CITY TO MACULA ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE SENATE CENTER
MOUNTAINS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
HE WAS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
COUNCILMEMBER ELECTED IN
CATHEDRAL CITY.
AND I WAS STILL A RELATIVELY NEW
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS CITY
COUNCILMAN FROM TO MACULA.
GREAT CARE A LOT ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION AND PLANNING
ISSUES IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND I CARED ABOUT THE SAME.
HE CARED ABOUT USING TAXPAYER
MONEY WISELY.
I CARED ABOUT THE SAME. FOR THE
DAY. ONE OF OUR FRIENDSHIP WE
KNEW THAT WE NEVER AGREE ON A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT NORMALLY
DIVIDE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
SO WE DECIDED TO FOCUS ON THE
THINGS THAT WE COULD AGREE ON
FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CITY'S IMMERSE I COUNTY GOT
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF STATE.
AND FEDERAL FUNDING.
WORKING TO CREATE A
TRANSPORTATIONSYSTEM THAT
WORKED FOR OUR AREA.
AND HELPING VETERANS IN THE WHEN
GREG WAS IN LINE TO ASSUME THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS NORMALLY CALLED
SKAGGS THE WORLD'S LARGEST.
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION.
THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTIES IT TRIED TO
CIRCUMVENT HIS ASCENSION. TO
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
I WAS VERY PROUD O TO WORK HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
HE GOT THE JOB AS PRESIDENT OF
SKAGGS.
AND HE ULTIMATELY DID GET THE
POSITION.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
ABOUT HALF THE POPULATION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I CAME TO RELY ON GRAY QUITE A
BIT AFTER I BECAME A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR.
AND SERVED AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD.
I DIDN'T KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
COACHELLA VALLEY PART OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BECAUSE I KEEP
IN THE WESTERN PART RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS A VERY.
LONG.
COUNTY ALMOST STRETCHES THE
WHOLE WITH OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS GREAT THAT REALLY
INTRODUCED ME TO MANY THE
LECTERN OFFICIALS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY BECAUSE I
WANTED TO KNOW WAS CHAIRMAN OF
THE BOARD NOT ONLY WAS GOING ON
THE WESTERN SIDE OF THE COUNTY
BUT HOW THE INTEGRATED WITH THE
EASTERN SIDE OF THE COUNTY.
WHEN I WAS ELECTED TO THE SENATE?
GREG PEDIS TOOK A LOT OF HEAT.
FOR A GREEN. TO JOIN MY STAFF.
AND I TOOK A LOT OF HEAT. FOR
HIRING HIM.
BUT HE WAS ONE OF THE BEST TIRES
I'VE EVER HAD.
AND SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS WELL.
A LIBERAL DEMOCRAT WORKING FOR
CONSERVE REPUBLICAN WHAT WAS THE
REAL COMING.
TO BUT REMEMBER WE BOTH VIEW
ELECTED OFFICE AS A WAY TO HELP
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WILL CALL OUR OFFICES
DON'T CARE ABOUT OUR POLITICAL
PARTY.
THERE'S ONE HELP.
AND GREG AND I SHARE THAT
PHILOSOPHY.
ALSO WHEN I RAN I PROMISED MY
STAFF.
YEAH THAT OF MY CONSTITUENTS
THAT MIGHT STAFF WOULD REFLECT
[inaudible]
MY CONSTITUENCY.
I HAVE A LARGE GAY CONSTITUENCY
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE THEY KNEW
THAT THEY HAD A VOICE.
IN MY OFFICE.
GREAT PEDIS WAS THE PERFECT FIT.
FROM MY COACHELLA VALLEY PART OF
MY SENATE DISTRICT.
AND LET ME TELL YOU OF THE GRAVE.
GAVE IT ALL.
AND HE WAS PASSIONATE AND
ARTICULATE VOICES FOR THE CAUSES
THAT HE CARED ABOUT.
I WAS PROUD TO WORK WITH HIM.
I WAS HONORED TO KNOW HIM.
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
FRIENDSHIP THAT WE SHARED.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
LETTING ME ADJOURN AND THE
MEMORY OF A MAN WHO MAY BE GONE
BUT WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN
BRAKE PAD US.
I HOPE YOU REST IN PEACE MY
FRIEND.
AND FELLOW SERVANT.
I ALSO WANT ANNOUNCES HE'S GOING
TO HAVE A MEMORIAL SERVICE.
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
ON FEBRUARY FIRST I WANT TO MAKE
AN OPEN INVITATION I KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF GOOD FRIENDS HERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HEARING FROM.
AND I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
YOUR HUMBLY INVITED TO THAT
MEMORIAL SERVICE TO HONOR HIS
LIFE.
BIGGEST PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS STONE VERY GREAT FROM
PLEASE SEND OUR CONDOLENCES.
ON THE PASSING OF MAYOR PEDIS
[inaudible]
THERE WINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS I ALSO --
RISE TO REQUEST A RETURN --
IN MEMORY OF GRAY PAD AS SOMEONE --
EXPRESS OUR CAUCUSES SINCEREST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS ENTIRE OUR
COMMUNITY --
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
CATHEDRAL CITY --
CITY COUNCIL MANY --
OPENLY LGBT ELECTED OFFICIALS --
IN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE SOME --
BUT NOT VERY MANY --
SO HE WAS A TRAILBLAZER --
IN MANY WAYS --
SHE DID --
INCREDIBLE WORK ON IN HIS ROLE
IN CITY COUNCIL --
HERO AND HELP HOUSE A RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SPUR CELL DPT NON
DISCRIMINATION ORDINANCE --
HE WAS ALSO A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES
LGBT CAUCUS WHICH IS A GROWING
AND THRIVING AKAKA'S TODAY --
HE ALSO DID JUST ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF WORK --
PASSING IN ADVOCATING FOR
PROGRESSIVE.
LEGISLATION FOR ALL MARGINAL A
GREAT LEADER --
AND OUR STATE --
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
REALLY -- TO
SHOCKS --
WHEN HE PASSED A AND --
MAY YOU REST IN PEACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER.
CENTER STONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
STAND FOR CHEN MEMORY IN MISSED
FOR MISTER DRAKE. FOR SURE SIR.
THANK YOU AGAIN A MEMBERS --
I RISE TODAY ALSO IN THE MEMORY
OF A A FRIEND BEEN BEEN DRAKE.
A TO MACULA WINE COUNTRY PIONEER
WHO PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER
SEVENTH AFTER.
A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER.
BEN LIVED INTO MACULA AREA FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS AND
PLANTED MANY THE VINEYARDS.
THAT THESE DAYS MAKE UP THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WINE COUNTRY.
HE SERVED ON THE RANCHO
CALIFORNIA WATER DISTRICT BOARD
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS INCLUDING
THREE YEARS AS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT.
HE WAS ALSO VERY INVOLVED
THROUGH DRAKE IN A PRICES AND
THE GROWING OF GRAPES AND
AVOCADOS AND RIVERSIDE AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES.
A PAST PRESIDENT OF THE TO MAKE
IT ABOUT A GREAT GROWERS
ASSOCIATION BEV ALL BEN ALSO
GAVE US TIME AND ENERGY. TO HELP
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AS CHAIRMAN
OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY FARM
BUREAU.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS UC
AGRICULTURAL WAS BEN'S LIFE.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN
THE GLASSY WINGED SHARPSHOOTER
BEGAN SPREADING PIERCE'S DISEASE
THE ROUTE THE TEMECULA VALLEY
DESTROYING THE VINEYARDS THEIR
AND THREATENING OTHERS ACROSS
THE REGION IN THE STATE WAS
BANNED. TO PLAYED A HUGE ROLE IN
HELPING CAN THIS DEADLY
BACTERIUM.
BEN WAS ALSO MY FRIEND AND CLOSE
ADVISER YOU SERVED ON MY KITCHEN
CABINET ADVISORY PANEL AND
BROUGHT HIS EXPERTISE AND
OPINIONS ABOUT.
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY SUCH A
LARGE INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE GROUP AND TO
THE COMMUNITY.
OUR STATE AND OUR COMMUNITY MAY
HAVE LOST A FRIEND WHEN BEEN
PASSED AWAY BUT HE WILL LIVE ON
THROUGH HIS FOUR CHILDREN AND
HIS WIFE SHARON.
WHO STOOD BY HIS SIDE WHEN THEY
WERE MARRIED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE INTO MACULA HE LOVED?
AND HELP MAKE SUCH A WONDERFUL
PLACE TO LIVE I APPRECIATE YOU
ADJOURNING IN HIS HONOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER STONE.
THE CENTER FOR MARINE.
TO THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
AND AS THE SENATE TO ADJOURN
TODAY IN MEMORY OF WILLIAM
O'MALLEY A DISTINGUISHED JUDGE.
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
SERVE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOR
MORE THAN THREE DECADES.
JUDGE O'MALLEY ACTUALLY CAME TO
THE LAW RELATIVELY LATE IN LIFE.
HE WAS A BOSTON BORN IRISH
AMERICAN.
I SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
NAVY DURING WORLD WAR TWO BEFORE
MOVING TO THE BAY AREA.
WITH A WIFE AND SEVEN KIDS TO
SUPPORT.
BILL MALLEY WENT TO LAW SCHOOL
WHILE WORKING IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
EARNING HIS LAW DEGREE AT THE
AGE.
FOR THIRTY EIGHT BUT HE MADE UP
FOR LOST TIME BECOMING AS A
FORMER COLLEAGUE SAID.
AN EXCEPTIONAL JURISTS
REMEMBERED FOR HIS PASSION FOR
JUSTICE.
BILL O'MALLEY HELPED CREATE THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
FORGETTING ELECTED FOUR TIMES AS
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY. NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR DURING HIS TENURE IS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
FUNDED CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IS
FIRST RATE CRISIS CENTER.
HE KEPT UP HIS DISTINGUISHED
LEGAL CAREER.
AS A CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE.
UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE FRIENDS
SAID BILL O'MALLEY WAS THE
CONSUMMATE MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
QUOTE IN HIS TIME HE COULD HAVE
BEEN ELECTED ANYTHING AND CONTRA
COSTA AND QUOTE.
A FORMER PARTNER ONCE SAID.
PERHAPS HIS GREATEST LEGACY IS
HIS FAMILY.
HE AND HIS WIFE CLEAR HAD NINE
CHILDREN THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
[inaudible]
SIX GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
HE WAS THE PATRIARCH OF ONE OF
THE BEST KNOWN FAMILIES IN THE
BAY AREA IS LEGAL COMMUNITY.
HIS DAUGHTER NANCY O'MALLEY IS
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TODAY.
HIS SON DAN O'MALLEY SERVED AS A
DEPUTY IS DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
AND JUDGE AND IS NOW IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE.
AND HIS GRANDDAUGHTER CALLING
CLARK IS A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
HIS WIFE CLAIRE WAS.
THE SOCIAL SERVICE ACTIVISTS WHO
COULD HELP FIND SHELTER FOOD AND
CLOTHING FOR ANYONE IN NEED.
EVEN IF IT MEANT OPENING UP HER
AROUND HOME.
SHE PROCEEDED BILL IN DEATH IN.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE BILL A
VALLEY WILL BE MISSED BY FRIENDS
AND COLLEAGUES AND HIS LARGE
FAMILY.
MY DEEP CONDOLENCES TO HIS
CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND I THANK MEMBERS FOR YEAR
AGREEMENT AND CHURNING IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER.
PLEASE ACCEPT OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES PLEASE PASS ALONG
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY
VERY GRATEFUL.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RETURN CENTER HER TARA. FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE.
I THINK MISTER PRESIDENT I ASK
ALL MEMBERS TO A WELCOME COUNCIL
MEMBER ARE PRE NO FROM.
THE CITY OF HANFORD HERE IS HERE
WITH US TODAY.
CITY COUNCIL EVER WELCOME TO
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
FOR TEN THANK YOU.
THE DISEASE --
THINKING.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR MORE LAW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE AND
ADJOURNMENTS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I I'D LIKE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A VERY
SPECIAL FRIEND.
JOANNA TOWNSEND WAS BORN ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY. NINETEEN FORTY
TWO IN COQUILLE ORGAN.
SHE WAS THE FIRST OF FIVE
CHILDREN BORN TO JOHN KINGSTON
AND JEAN HANSON.
YOUR HANNAH GAVE HER LIFE.
THE LORD AT THE FIRST ASSEMBLY
OF GOD CHURCH OF COQUILLE AT AGE.
THIRTEEN SHE WOULD THEN DEVOTE
HER LIFE TO EVANGELIZING
CHILDREN.
SHE GRADUATED FROM COQUILLE HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SIXTY AND AT
THE URGING OF HER FATHER TO
LEAVE HOME IT.
AGE EIGHTEEN SHE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA.
THERE SHE LIVED WITH HER
GRANDPARENTS IMPORTANT AND TELL
MOVING ONTO THE CAMPUS OF THEN --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
WHICH WOULD BECOME MORE RENAMED
VANGUARD UNIVERSITY.
SHE EARNED A DEGREE IN
LITERATURE AND BECAME A FIFTH
GRADE TEACHER FOR GARDEN GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HE LATER WENT BACK TO SCHOOL AND
EARNED A MASTER'S IN THEOLOGY
FROM VANGUARD UNIVERSITY.
SHE MET HER HUSBAND JIM TOWNSEND
AT CALVARY CHAPEL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TO IN COSTA MESA AND
THEY WERE MARRIED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE JOE
HANNAH SERVE AS CHILDREN'S
PASTOR AT NEWPORT MESA CHRISTIAN
CENTER IN COSTA MESA FROM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE TO
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHERE SHE
INVESTED IN THE LIVES OF
COUNTLESS CHILDREN.
YOUR HAND IS INTEGRITY MORAL
CHARACTER AND KIND SPIRIT MADE
HER A NATURAL LEADER AMONG YOUR
PEERS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SHE RECEIVED
THE ACTUAL CHILDREN'S PASTORS
CONFERENCE.
JOHANNES COMMITMENT ALONG WITH
OUR DEDICATION AND CONCERN FOR
CHILDREN.
MADE HER AN INVALUABLE PLAYER ON
ANYONE'S TEAM.
A GOOD LEADER MUST BE A GOOD
FOLLOWER JOE HANNAH HAD THE
UNIQUE ABILITY TO BE BOTH.
HE HELPED START WHAT IS KNOWN AS
ROYAL FAMILY KIDS CAMP.
A VERY SUCCESSFUL NOW NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES CAMP.
FOR SUMMER CAMP FOR ABUSED KIDS.
AND SHE WROTE THE INITIAL
CURRICULUM --
SHE HAD A PROFOUND IMPACT ON MY
LIFE MISTER PRESIDENT --
THE ATTENDANCE AT HER MEMORIAL
SERVICE OF IMPACTED FRIENDS FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY WITH AN
AMAZING TESTIMONY TO THE IMPACT.
THIS DEAR WOMAN HAD ON SO MANY
SOJOURNERS.
MY FAMILY WILL MISS HER.
FRIENDSHIP.
GENEROSITY AND COUNSEL.
THANK YOU FOR THE HONOR. TO
ADJOURN INTER HAND AS MEMORY AND
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO KEEP.
HER HUSBAND JIM TOWNSEND AND THE
FAMILY IN OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS AT THIS TIME OF LOS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR MOORLACH PLEASE
PASS ON OUR DEEP CONDOLENCES.
CENTER READ FOR THE LIKE TO JOIN
IN THE RESEARCH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF A GREAT.
LABOR LEADER --
GREAT LABOR WARRIOR THAT IN THE
PERSON OF DAVID ARIANNA ON
JANUARY SECOND --
MISTER ARIAN LOSSES LIFE --
TO AFTER BATTLE WITH THYROID
CANCER BUT HE SERVED THE SAN
PEDRO HARBOR COMMUNITY WITH
GREAT DISTINCTION FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS.
AS PRESIDENT OF AIW TENURE.
AS A LONGSHOREMAN.
THESE ALL ALSO WAS LA HARBOR
COMMISSIONER AT THE TIME OF HIS
PASSING.
MR ERIN WAS BORN ON DECEMBER
FOURTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX AND AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN TOOK HIS
FIRST JOB.
ALL IN THE WOMAN ONE TO
WATERFRONTS AND ON THE FIRST DAY
OF UNLOADING BANANAS --
WOULD.
STRIKING IN IN HIM A DESIRE TO
CONTINUE THIS WORK AND AND
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE SAN PEDRO --
AREA AND MANY WOULDN'T.
WOULD.
ARE THERE TODAY BECAUSE OF HIS
GREAT ORGANIZING SKILLS IN HIS
LEADERSHIP --
OUT THROUGHOUT THE OF THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION I'M SORRY AND THE
GREATER ST PETER COMMUNITY.
AS A MEMBER OF AYE O. W. YOU.
LOCAL THIRTEEN MISTER AREA HELD
MANY LEADERSHIP POSITIONS OVER
THE YEARS AND WAS ELECTED TO THE
PRESIDENT AT THE AGE OF FORTY
FOUR WITHIN A YEAR OF HIS
RETIREMENT IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
HE WAS APPOINTED.
BY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HARBOR COMMISSION WHERE HE
SERVED AND CONTINUE TO SERVE OF
THE FIVE MEMBER PANEL UNTIL THE
TIME OF HIS DEATH.
DURING THE TENURE ON THE BOARD.
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES BROKE
ALL TIME CARGO VOLUME RECORDS
WHILE REDUCING AIR MISSIONS TO
GOALS WHICH SHE WAS.
CONSTANTLY FOCUSED ON AND
COMMITTED TO MR ERIN WAS A
TIRELESS LEE --
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS AND WAS A
KIND ORDER MANY LOCAL.
ORGANIZATIONS OUT THROUGHOUT THE
HARBOR IN TEMPE JUROR AREA HE
ALSO FOUND A DAIRY BRIDGES
INSTITUTED MISTER BRIDGES WAS A
LEGENDARY ORGANIZER'S WELL DOWN
IN THE HARBOR AREA.
AND ORGANIZATION I WAS DEDICATED
TO EDUCATING YOUNGER WORKERS
ABOUT THE LABOR MOVEMENT'S RICH
HISTORY AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
CONCERNED SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMUNITY WAS ALWAYS AT THE
FOREFRONT MISTER AARON
EVERYTHING THESE --
HE SAID HE WAS COMMITTED.
TO OUT HIS SURVIVE BUYS TWO
CHILDREN FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED NOT
ONLY BY THE HIS FAMILY BUT BY
THE ENTIRE --
SAMPI JOIN --
GREATER HARPER COMMUNITY AND ON
THE LABOR MOVEMENT AS WELL ICE
RING GERMANS MEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
BRADFORD PLEASE PASS ON OUR
CONDOLENCES.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER JOURNEY
MEMORY FOR SENATOR AWESOME YES I
JUST WANT TO ADD A FEW WORDS --
FROM THE LOS ANGELES LABOR
MOMENT I WANT TO ADD HOW BROTHER
DAVE ARIAN WAS A LONGSHOREMAN
NOT ONLY FROM THE FIRST DAY HE
STARTED WORKING ON THE DOCKS BUT
ALL THE WAY.
TO THE THE LAST DAY OF THE LAST
BREATH THAT HE TOOK HE WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY RANK AND FILE
LEADER.
WHICH VERY FEW --
RANK AND FILE MEMBERS BECOME
THOSE KINDS OF LEADERS AND BE
AND STAY AS CONNECTED TO THE
RANK AND FILE AS HE DID.
I WAS PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO OR GO
ON A TRIP WITH HIM TO CHINA AND
DIDN'T MATTER HE DIDN'T KNOW THE
LANGUAGE HE DIDN'T MATTER WHAT
THE POLITICS ARE GOING ON HE WAS
THERE TO CONNECT WITH LONG SURE
WORKERS WHO DID THE SAME KINDS
OF THINGS.
AND JUST WANTED --
TO BE ABLE TO RAISE I ALSO ASK --
FOR SUPPORT AND AN HONOR FOR
BROTHER DAVE AREA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR DRAWS OF
SANTA ROSA WOULD YOU ALSO LIKE
TO ADD ADVANTAGE IN MEMORY FOR
MISTER GONZALEZ AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
MY GOOD FRIEND ON DOING YOUR
GONZALEZ HE PASSED AWAY ON
SUNDAY NOVEMBER ELEVENTH.
AFTER A BATTLE WITH CANCER HE
WAS PRESIDENT OF THE SOUTHWEST
VOTER REGISTRATION AND EDUCATION
PROJECT.
AND THE WILL OF ALASKA'S
INSTITUTE TO TRAIL BLAZING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK TO
EMPOWER THE LATINO COMMUNITY.
UNTIL YOU'RE DEDICATED HIS LIFE
FROM MOBILIZING VOTERS AND
TRAINING COMMUNITY LEADERS TO
BECOME POLITICAL CANDIDATES. TO
ALSO FINDING SOLUTIONS TO THE
KINDS OF SYSTEMIC BARRIERS THAT
ARE COMMUNITIES FACE.
DURING HIS TENURE --
THE ORGANIZATION HELPED TO
TRIPLE LET THE NOTE REGISTRATION
FROM FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO FIFTEEN
MILLION IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN HE HELPED TO
INCREASE LATINO VOTING.
FROM NEARLY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION TO TWELVE MILLION.
IN TWENTY YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE ON TONYA
WAS NAMED ONE OF THE INFLUENTIAL
LATINOS IN AMERICA BY TIME
MAGAZINE.
HE WAS A CHAMPION FOR OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES HE DEDICATED HIS
LIFE AGAINST TO FIGHTING AGAINST
ALL ANTI IMMIGRANT AND ANTI
LATINO POLICIES.
A REAL GRASSROOTS ORGANIZERS HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE ALMA
MARTINEZ DAUGHTERS CEREMONIES
AVAIL GONZALEZ.
MOTHER BROTHERS SISTERS AND
FAMILY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING ON DOING IS LEGACY AND
SEND IN OUR HEARTFELT
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS CENTER AS A
PLEASE SEND OUR CONDOLENCES --
MR MAJORITY LEADER ON THIS ITEM
GO YES ON THIS ITEM LIKE JUST
BRIEFLY JOINED IN --
YOU KNOW ONE TWENTY WAS A FRIEND
OF MINE I I THINK BACK AND I
DON'T REMEMBER WHEN I MET HIM
HOW MANY DECADES AGO.
THESE DREADED OLD VW AND I
REMEMBER USED.
TO MAKE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR THAT THE NO CAT IT'S THAT HE
BELIEVED IN THAT EXCEEDED HIS
MONTHLY SALARY.
AND AND HE WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE
KINDS OF FOLKS THAT.
LEAVE THE EVERY PARTOF HIS BODY
HE JUST WAS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
WHEN YOUR HOST TO HELP WITH THEM
AND TALK TO HIM HE ALWAYS WAS A
WAR YOU ALWAYS FIGHT AND HE WAS
ALWAYS ENGAGED.
HE WAS AN IMPRESSIVE FELLOW HIS
WIFE ALMA ON OUR OWN RIGHT
GLORIA MOLINA IS CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR EITHER OF YOU START HERE'S A
FOLLOW IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN
GLORY WAS SELECTED. NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND WAS WITH HER FOR
SO MANY YEARS IN PART OF A TEAM
THEY REALLY WERE JUST
EXTRAORDINARY TEAMS I JUST WANT
TO JOIN IN WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES.
IN THE CHURNING IN HIS MEMORY
YOU'VE MADE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA AND
THERE WAS NOTED ACROSS UNITED
STATES.
THINK MRS.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TURN
THE FLOOR OVER FOR TO A JOURNEY
MEMORIES SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WHICH PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IS CHAIR OF THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE TO HONOR AND A GERMAN
A MEMORY OF ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS.
A DECORATED MILITARY VETERAN
DOCTOR FREDERICK EIGHT BERGERSEN
OF WHITTIER CALIFORNIA.
DR BERGERSEN SHIRT IN THE ARMY
DURING VIETNAM WITH THE RENOWNED
FIRST CALVARY AIR MOBILE
DIVISION EARNING THE RANK OF
CAPTAIN.
WITH THE FIRST CALVARY.
MR BERGESON PARTICIPATED RELIEF
OF QUE SON.
AND RECEIVED THE BRONZE STAR FOR
HIS MERITORIOUS ACHIEVEMENT AND
ASSISTING IN THE PLANNING OF THE
SUCCESSFUL RELIEF OF THE BASE.
AFTER VIETNAM DOCTOR BERGERSEN.
WAS A WILLIAM C. FOSTER FELLOW
FIRST IN THE US ARMS CONTROL
INTO AND THIS MARMOT.
AGENCY AND LATER IN THE US STATE
DEPARTMENT.
DURING HIS TENURE AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT DOCTOR BERGESON WAS
YOU WAS ONE OF MANY BRAVE PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO HELPED EVACUATE.
THE DEPARTMENT BUILDING DURING
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AND THE
ATTACK.
DOCTOR VERSION WAS ALSO.
AS BEEN A VALUED MEMBER OF THE
WITH YOUR COMMUNITY FOR OVER
FOUR DECADES WHERE HE WAS A
PROFESSOR AT WHITTIER COLLEGE
ALSO IN MY DISTRICT.
AT WHAT YOU'RE COLLEGES SERVED.
ONE OF THE LONGEST TENURES OF
ANY PROFESSOR IN THE COLLEGE
HISTORY.
IN THE CLASSROOM DOCTOR BERGSON
PROFESSOR WHO WERE DETERMINED TO
HELP STUDENTS ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHEST POTENTIAL.
AROUND CAMPUS DR BIRDS AND WAS
KNOWN FOR ITS JEWEL ATTITUDE
INFECTIOUS HUMOR.
DOCTOR BURKE CENTER WHICH IS
ABOUT MEMBER OF THE JEWISH FAITH.
AND EXEMPLIFIED THE BEST IN
HUMOR CHARM GENEROSITY KINDNESS
YOU MENTALLY.
N.. FOR THESE REASONS I ASKED TO
RETURN IN HIS HONOR.
AND AS MEMORY.
PLEASE PASS ALONG OUR DEEP
CONDOLENCES WHICH SENATOR.
MISTER SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE THE FINAL
JOURNEY MEMORY FOR MISTER GANG.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS HIGH
RISE TODAY IS CHAIR OF THE
BETTORS COMMITTEE TO HONOR AND
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A
DECORATED MILITARY VETERAN.
WILLIAM C. GORDON GANG OF RANCHO
SANTA FE'S CALIFORNIA.
WILLIAM WAS BORN IN.
DODD PRINCE REPORT CANADA IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AND MOVED TO
UNITED STATES AT THE AGE OF
SEVEN WERE BECAME A CITIZEN AND
LATER ACHIEVING.
THE GOAL IS TO BECOME ONE OF
AMERICA'S BEST ANY GRADUATED
FROM WEST POINT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX HE ATTENDED AIRBORNE.
JUMPMASTER IN RANGERS SCHOOLS
ANY SERVICE ACTIVE DUTY FOR
EIGHT YEARS WHICH INCLUDED BEING
A COMBAT ENGINEER COMPANY
COMMANDER.
YOU'RE AN OFFENSIVE OPERATIONS
IN VIETNAM.
HE RETIRED AS A COLONEL AND
SPECIAL OPERATIONS OFFICER IN
THE ARMY RESERVES IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE WITH THREE BRONZE
STARS TO MERITORIOUS SERVICE
MEDALS AND TWO AIR MEDALS THE
VIETNAMESE GALLANTRY.
CROSS.
OR FOR VALOR.
BILL COMPLETED HIS MASTER'S IN
NUCLEAR ENGINEERING AT MIT IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY AND HIS MBA IN
FINANCE FROM.
FAIRLY DIXON UNIVERSITY IN NEW
JERSEY.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR HE LEFT
THAT DUTY AND ENTERED THE
RESERVES AND EMBARKED ON A
CAREER AS A MANAGER FOR GENERAL
ELECTRIC.
OVER THE NEXT FORTY FOUR YEARS
COLONEL GANG.
WORKED IN BOTH THE NUCLEAR AND
NON YOUR AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROBABLY SERVED AS CIVILIAN AID
TO THE SECTOR OF THE ARMY FOR
CALIFORNIA SOUTH.
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND SIX TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS SUCH HE
DEDICATED HIS TIME IS LIFE
EXPERTISE TO THE ARMY NATIONAL
TRAINING CENTER.
AND FORT IRWIN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE PROVISIONAL HIM
APPRECIATED HIS KEEN INTELLECT.
WISE COUNSEL INTENSE A DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE TRYING DEMEANOR AND
HIS LIVELY SENSE OF HUMOR.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
KATHRYN.
WITH WHOM HE CELEBRATE FIFTY
YEARS OF MARRIAGE LAST MAY IS
CHILDREN CATALINA ANTHONY
NICHOLAS AND HIS SISTER JUDITH
AND THE STEP BROTHER HER.
AND FOR THESE REASONS I ASKED TO
RETURN IN HIS MEMORY.
GRATEFULNESS ARCHULETA IN IF YOU
COULD PLEASE SEND OUR DEEPEST.
CONDOLENCES TO THE COLONEL'S
FAMILY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ADVANCING BOTH OF THOSE TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
MADAM PRO TEM.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
A THANKYOU MISTER PRESIDENT
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE UNDER.
OUGHT MOTIONS AND ANNOUNCEMENTS
ARE UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
THE RULES COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN
ROOM --
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND OTHER
THAN THAT MISTER PRESIDENT I
WOULD SAY THAT WE WILL RECONVENE
ON TUESDAY NOT MONDAY HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE WILL ENJOY.
THE MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY
CELEBRATIONS ALL OVER THE STATE
SO THEREFORE WE WILL RECONVENE
ON TUESDAY AT TWO PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT TWO
PM.
ALL RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
BE NEEDING IMMEDIATELY UPON A
GERMAN IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE HAVE A
GOOD WE CAN MEMBERS